في مبنى غير موصوف في أوروبا ،
توجد غرفة تسمى الخزنة ، حيث يتم تسجيل ما يقرب من
800000 وثيقة مهربة من سوريا
وترجمتها.
الحكومات الغربية في هذه
الصناديق هي دليل محتمل على جرائم مزعومة
يمكن استخدامها في يوم من الأيام
ضد نظام الرئيس السوري
بشار الأسد. تغطي الوثائق مجموعة
واسعة من المعلومات ومستويات
القيادة حتى تبدأ من أعلى
مستويات القيادة التي  قم بتضمين
المعلومات وتمكن الرئيس
وصانعو السياسات على المستوى الوطني
من الحصول على قدر كبير من الوضوح حول
كيفية صعود الأوامر وهبوطها في التسلسل
القيادي ، وكيفية تنفيذ المسؤوليات على
أعلى مستوى للسياسة
بطريقة تمكننا من  يمكن رؤية
الإجرام يحدث فعليًا على
الأرض ، ولا توجد وثيقة واحدة هنا تدل
على وجود مسدس دخان. ب  بالنسبة
للعدالة الجنائية الدولية
، يتعلق الأمر بربط الجرائم بتلك
الوثائق المسؤولة مثل أمر 2011 هذا الذي
يأذن بزيادة رواتب
الأفراد العسكريين الذي وقعه الرئيس
الأسد ،
قد يبدو القائد العام للقوات المسلحة غير ضار ، لكن
الزاوية تقول إنه حتى هذا دليل حاسم.
لديها العديد من الوثائق التي
تشبه ذلك مع تسمية الأسد
وغيره من الذين يبرهنون على
أنهم مسيطرون ولديهم القدرة على
توجيه الجيش والأجهزة الأمنية
، وهي حقيقة أن الجيش وأجهزته
الأمنية مستمرون في
ارتكاب الجرائم و  هؤلاء الأفراد
لا يفعلون أي شيء لوقف الاستيلاء عليه ،
وقد أقاموا عشرات القضايا
ضد النظام معظمها تتعلق
بالأيام الأولى للثورة
والقمع العنيف للاحتجاجات
والتعذيب والقتل المزعوم لآلاف
المتظاهرين المحتجزين في جميع أنحاء
البلاد
منذ عام 2012 و  ظلال الحرب
التي أطلقت العنان لبعض من أسوأ
الفظائع في عصرنا شبكة من المزيد
أكثر من مائة سوري تم
تجنيدهم وتدريبهم من قبل الشجاعة ، لدينا فرصة نادرة
لمقابلة أحد
صيادي المستندات الذين يتعامل معهم لأنه يريد أن
يتم استدعاؤه كان محامياً الآن لديه هذا
الفريق الذي خاطر بكل شيء
لحفظ الأدلة جميع أعضاء فريقنا.  تعرض
رجال ونساء الفريق للاعتقالات
أو الضرب أو الإهانة أو الخطر ،
فنحن نعمل في منطقة حرب في معظم
الحالات ندخل مناطق حيث ستكون الغارات الجوية
مستمرة ولكن يتعين علينا الذهاب
لجمع الأدلة قبل
إتلافها للتعامل معها و  زملائه
الباحثين عن الأدلة كنزًا دفينًا من
الوثائق خلفتها
البيروقراطية الشائنة للنظام بعد أن
استولى الجيش السوري الحر على مواقع من
الحكومة مثل المواقع العسكرية أو الاستخباراتية ،
ستكون فرقنا جاهزة
وستدخل هذه المواقع ،
مهمتها الأساسية للحفاظ على هذه المواقع.  الوثائق أو
ما تبقى منها لأنه في كثير من الحالات
سيتم إتلاف هذه الوثائق
لم تعتمد CJ فقط على الأدلة
التي تم جمعها  د من خلال شبكتها الخاصة من
المحققين في عدد من القضايا ،
قاموا بدمج ذلك مع بعض من
أكثر الأدلة البصرية إدانة لهذا
الصراع ، حيث تمكنت 28000 صورة مروعة
لمعتقلين متوفين تم تهريبها في عام 2013 من قبل
منشق عسكري يُدعى سيزر سجا.
- الإشارة إلى
أرقام التعريف الموجودة في هذه
الصور مع تلك الموجودة في الوثائق المهربة
مما يتيح لهم التعرف على
بعض الأسرى وربطهم
بمنشآت معينة والجهاز الأمني
ي كان يحتجزهم ، وكانت إحدى تل
الصور من تلك الأرقام 30 أو
دام حميد كالاني و  لقد قرأت أنت لي ،
طالب القانون المحتجز في أبريل 2012 ،
شقيقته أمينة ، التي نجت من
سجون الحكومة الآن ، وهي لاجئة في المملكة المتحدة ،
وهي شهادة حية على وحشية النظام السوري
يا أبي ، حليفه الصغير ،
وثائق البدادي الصادرة عن النظام ادعت أن
الآلاف محتجزون في منشآته كلها.
توفي لأسباب طبيعية
، كما تم اعتقال ثلاثة أشقاء آخرين من عائلة الجيلاني ،
كما تم اعتقال أحدهم فقط بلال
هـ  اندمج على قيد الحياة بشهادة وجهه الهزيلة
على الفظائع داخل سجون الحكومة
وفقًا لتحقيقات CJ ، إنها
قصة تكررت آلاف المرات
في سوريا حيث ينتشر التعذيب
والاعترافات المنتظمة والقسرية
هي القاعدة التي لم يستجب مسؤولو الحكومة السورية
لطلبات متعددة
للتعليق ولكن  رفض النظام مرارًا وتكرارًا
الأدلة المزيفة وأصر على أنه كان
يحارب الإرهابيين وليس
المتظاهرين السلميين لا تزال أمينة لاني
تدعو بشدة إلى تحقيق العدالة لأشقائها ، لكنها
مثل العديد من السوريين الآخرين تخشى
ألا تعيش أبدًا لترى النظام
يُحاسب على جرائمه مثل
بشار-  يبدو أن الأسد قد تحدى
احتمالات النجاة من ثورة الآن وهو
على وشك الفوز في الحرب
، تغير المد والجزر وما
نتأكد منه هو أنه عندما يأتي التحول
عندما يظهر النقاش حول العدالة
في 5 أو 10  أو 20 عامًا على أنه
سيكون هناك دليل على أن الأدلة
التي تم جمعها بواسطة السيجا قد تم استخدامها بالفعل
في الأفراد  المحاكمات في الولايات
المتحدة في أوروبا ، أدت أيضًا إلى
اعتقال واحد على الأقل
من أعضاء النظام من المستوى المتوسط في ألمانيا متهمًا با
تعذيب بسبب التعامل ، هذه مجرد ال
داية ودعت زوجتي وأ
لادي وأخبرتهم أنني لم أع
لك أنا الآن ملك لسوريا
والعدالة التي يقول
إنها واجب لا عودة عنه
جيمانا كراتشي سي إن إن.